selena i want to first congratulate you
on your grammy um amazing how does it
feel thank you so much um i cried like a
little baby i was very excited um and i
worked really hard on that project so it
was
a lovely surprise i'm very excited
well congrats we're proud of you let's
get to this movie all right let's talk
um we're back for a fourth hotel tea i
am not mad about it i am a little bit
sad that this could be the last one i
say could because at this point we never
say never in hollywood anymore because
everything gets rebooted what do you
guys think andy start with you you tell
me what what do you think why do we keep
coming back to this series what feels so
good about it for some reason it feels
like a family movie every time i watch
it but it's about monsters well a family
of monsters right and the intermingling
of monsters and humans and
cross-generational and
you know it's really just so warm and
silly and
it's classic monster
characters that i think have lasted for
a really long time for a reason they're
really fun to watch and their mythology
is interesting and
this is sort of a movie that takes those
things that we all know as viewers and
has fun with them and sort of lightens
it up a little bit and you know
the proof is in the pudding with kids if
they like it and they talk about it and
they want to see more they're going to
get more that's just how it works
um what is going on
[Music]
well listen my kiddo loves this thing he
loves the franchise but he just thought
that taking monsters and switching and
flipping the rolls was amazing selena
what's your take on that why do you
think people love this thing so much
well it's it's really it's kind of like
what andy said i
think it's really funny i think it's
funny for adults and and kids and
you know i have two sisters
um and it is one of the coolest things
ever when that's all they care about and
you know but it's it's awesome so i i
think also the messages i want to say
the messages behind each of the of the
films you know whether it's like
embracing being different or family
coming together and
uh trusting each other i think that's
also something
parents and and people enjoy about it is
that there is something underneath it
now you mentioned your sisters your
sister victoria is is joining in in this
thing right with some of the voice over
help what was that like yeah it was so
sweet she was visiting me when i was
shooting only murders and she came into
the session and there's a part for baby
mavis and she's never done anything
before and i like picked her up and i
was like can you do this and she was so
excited so she thought it was the
coolest experience i honestly won sister
points that is that is awesome um let's
talk storyline real quick so everything
is is out of whack as i kind of
mentioned drack has become this
hilarious
version of a human and and and johnny is
is
making my fathering to my son next to
impossible because he's transforming
into a monster do you guys relate to the
theme at all of of going to limits to
kind of fit in or be accepted do you
relate to that theme i mean i think
everyone does right at some point in
their life anytime you're put in a new
situation and you're not on solid ground
or familiar ground and that's what makes
us all who we are we figure out
different ways to navigate life and
feel accepted and that's why when you
find people that you feel like really
see you for who you are you you stick
with them and
yeah it's the
social part of being alive and being
humans instead of any other animal what
about you selena anything on it i think
it's it's hard because i i guess i grew
up right when all the instagram and
everything stuff was going on so
um
not to make it a sad answer but of
course you know as a young girl it was
really hard for me and i compared myself
terribly to a lot of people and
thought that i should be a certain way
but it's the joy of getting older is
you're learning to love who you are and
i'm slowly doing that and i'm really
proud and
you know every day is uh like a andy
said a choice for sure well said um do
you guys i know we already kind of said
never say never right and that this is
supposed to be the end but this guy over
here is hoping that it's not the end
do you get sad at all when you have to
put characters like these to sleep and
you're not really going to use them
again yeah i really am i mean it's been
so fun getting the reaction the past 10
years from families and from
um kids so it's it's a little
bittersweet it's you know i kind of felt
that way when wizards ended you know i i
felt like i was leaving behind a huge
part of who i was and growing up so it
was
it's bittersweet
yeah what about you andy playing johnny
what i mean
it could be the end it could not be the
end but but how do you feel about it
yeah absolutely i mean over the span
am i frozen again no no you're good
you're good sorry
oh gosh
this has to
this is crazy okay he's you're back now
you're good
am i here
you're here i hear you
so yeah i was sad
[Laughter]
he's like that's all i can get in i was
sad i loved it
and it was sad
and i hope we do more anyway even though
they said it was the last one you get it
yeah we got it all we got it off
[Music]